I love the way that was just super super
good to see but once those headsets are
on there now
the button takes her completely it is
tournament time it doesn't matter who's
on the other side the objective is to
get the done you gotta bring the a game
see that's the thing has so many weak
players here brought to their a-game but
you know some players are bringing their
s question yes that's the difference
okay you're gonna need the s plus plus
so you may get it into the final the
world I wonder do you think about uh
fatigue to write the guys that are
coming in from the LCQ yes are they
gonna have exactly momentum on their
side or is it gonna be something like
they might be burnout I mean they'll
definitely have momentum right it's like
oh my god I made it their dive into a
piece of a buddy but where does the
drive run from some of these guys might
have endless swells of energy right now
Omega D are opening it up nice to sum it
up in there see what he does he was
doing something he was like dancing in
his face
jumps out of there gets the sidestep to
avoid the additional hit well scoop just
alone and not quick enough on the jaw to
get the follow-up one this you know
greatly country on that
the ball here let's see what he does
great presence of mine knows he was able
to low-profile that one more he could do
it got the challenge right there but
hold on tomahawk not to be outdone this
man is to fit the pig Sebastian oh yeah
he got a pixel left he still alive he's
good but unfortunately that whip there
caused the punish and Omega D are taking
that round cool and that's the thing is
a persistence with tomahawks as well
he's always going for grabs both the
post keeping that pressure taking a step
nice block there on below taking
advantage of that positioning to get
that hop in there look to what sag and
he can't block this he was caught
engineers yeah this is a really bad
situation cuz now not only is eating all
this damage but he's still flashing red
this is a very very bad to wait forever
smart move there yeah really no other
decision in that situation but gets the
pick up now me carry still in control
big challenge I like it all and he went
outside but look at that and he keeps
him there with a Tod oh my god look at
this easy good position yeah baby do you
are really position you know what what
block move away from like the read
gauges immediately got back on its if
you can think to curses active curse oh
he tried to go for there but the thing
is again with tomahawk here he does have
meet her he's getting oh never mind
yeah you want to try finishing sentence
Omega dr doesn't care for your thoughts
or your home instead he just wants to
you see that yes we talking
I mean back to back ring out has to be
one of the better feelings in caliber
yes I didn't even have to finish my food
I just toss it when no one was looking
look at that feeling himself here and
right rightfully so rightfully so here
going into match number two I would
assume that tomahawk will take the
rematch option oh yeah item select stage
two
get out of there to be stage is not very
not very nice to him at all
especially if he's putting himself in a
risk where he likes to treat position a
lot he could be putting himself in the
unfavorable position just going in
offensively anyways here we go p10
election has plenty of floor to work
around this tomahawk it doesn't have to
worry about any ring outs fantastic Doug
they own the follow-ups first the
follow-up here but the reversal they
just see what kind of opportunity we're
gonna have some walk he's an aggressor
he does win this out was a combo in his
favor to go for the offensive read and
gets the knife follow I'm looking for
the castle trying to get omega dr to
jump paid out something in time walk in
control also built a lot of peter as
well any challenge not afraid and
anything at all throws up three be right
into the fantastic hop again tomahawk
doing a lot of that this time the room
for it into nothing go make at the are
fantastic reaction to take advantage but
right back at you
he'll flip takes a ghost guys a kind of
mix-up are we gonna see here again
decide go over the bid option he's nice
able to delay just to get the extra
damage in the back
go to the ground with Kensi and Tom off
using that momentum that he carried over
the first round Wow Wow look at this he
is putting the rush arms on omega dr i
love you utilizing boobs that you barely
have access throughout the set for round
and a beautiful stuff day Omega I just
hadn't seen the throw coming how does
the stand sit right on cue it safety
there for tomahawk realizing they end up
to worry about and I'll baby keep you
safe and stay in control
however sidestep the third time's the
charm and you always get one clean right
here it is follow-up this man has
snapped
he's gonna get some momentum going back
his way he's gonna have a nice life lead
but he's gonna have to he's gonna have
to dig deep he's gonna have to dig dig
because right now Tom Hogg he smells
blood I actually love this whole charge
he wasn't in now a fantastic dunk here
to start us what can't beat a game
sealer to tie it up at one apiece but
instead no it's just for bubble Maitre
D' are working on that garden gates but
gets the launched just in time mix up
ghost yes he saw that so many times
Omega deer has been scouting out you
know the 98 going for the local but he's
been switching up with the bees
committing to it and able to get in you
know it's not safe just going for it
he's going for because he knows that his
opponents gonna try to duck I love that
man players who put their fate in their
own hands you don't figure the odds like
yeah he actually did that yes he did he
wanted it and he wanted it now oh yeah
one game apiece we've been going down to
the final game a lot these guys are
hungry some of the highest levels
again pulling them inwards there oh and
look at that lethal hit use prepared for
it thanks for the warning you know
telling me to get ready Omega not
worried at all in that situation about
how that stomach respond back to back oh
that was clutch and it was a life-saving
reversal edge what's it gonna be staying
on the offense I think it's just going
to block no reason to challenge anything
their buckets clip oh just stop going
for the low ping as a chase
oh and he got up and hit him out of it
look at that knowing that he had the
option to stop as well that's great
stuff great presence of mind there from
Omega do that's just poise you know he's
been in a situation with one too many
times he's known all of it you know so
in control he caught him again oh but
this is big this is big all right he's
gonna get him again one more time here
with this critical edge tomahawks gonna
have to realize here that he's not in a
good situation to be very very careful
going up attacking the legs immediately
but no getting lost he's gonna get to
the point you better come quick the sake
extremely fast up close there you go not
having any of it put goes under the high
this time pulls him back
nice punish down from tomahawk Oh into
ducking yeah another wall sending me
series and look at that tomahawk able to
tie it up has to there's no other way
nice check knock knock yellow guard
gauge rich you got a team and yo just so
much yeah everything started hitting
there in that situation he tried to get
him with the throw and he got to get
with the C before I lost that other bar
meter so time I spent both parts but
just in the perfect phrase for that to
connect a huge chunk of generous damage
coming through at the right time oh yeah
he definitely made use of that meter
already gets the break the follow up
here all the wallet messed up is
positioning off very unfortunate
situations you have to be ready for all
of that caliber it does to you what time
walk so very much I didn't knock him out
of the sea he not gonna have that and I
can't just stress how big this round was
at tomahawk now in the lead so many
times have we seen him go to that tough
position on that string and come up with
the route while rising P come on look at
the close things out oh baby Dior does
have meter those
to be wary of how it's gonna be used and
the thing is either way he is starting
to whittle away using that pressure
using the throws what I was scarier up
yeah I'm not gonna have you get the
lethal hit and this could be curtains
what are you gonna do tomahawk tombak
has a huge lead trying to take advantage
watching the legs going all over with
the mix-ups glory holds the door
tomahawk with the fist pump of happiness
there as it spins into the Luther's top
Oh make it they are gonna go home and
ninth with that one and the last chances
ending for the majority of the crowd
here today
8 please remain one spot available and
before we get into that